cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now with more on the drug
that the president trump is taking
good morning to you dr aegis is there
any proof that hydroxychloroquine
can prevent covid for the president or
anybody else well let's just start with
the decision to take a medicine is one
of the most personal things you can do
and it involves a discussion of a
patient to a doctor
with the risk how close and how
significant interactions did he have
with this staff member
and the risks of the medicine and they
made that decision together given his
risk for complication
from covet there was data that
hydroxychloroquine could potentially
have a benefit
in cell culture dishes and in some pilot
studies in other countries
it looked encouraging encouraging so
that the nih
and universities across the country have
started clinical trials to say
does it actually work in patients with
early covid19 and the results are back
so the answer is
we don't know yet but this is a
political football when you talk about
this
it defines your politics whether you're
for or against hydroxychloroquine
and that's not right the data have to
speak and hopefully the data will be out
soon
but as a doctor would you recommend that
a patient take a
prescription drug for something they say
they don't have
well the the fda when it approves a drug
as a doctor you can use
it for any indication it is legal it's
called off-label use
and we do it significantly in the cancer
space
so what we know with covid19 is the data
look and appear that the earlier you
treat
the better the outcome so with each
individual
patient you look and you say what's the
risk that there's going to be
complications for this patient
and maybe you'd want to be a little bit
more aggressive with the president of
the united states
there has yet to be a medicine that's
been shown to work early some have
worked late when dissevere worked late
in the disease
and significantly shortened
hospitalization in a placebo-controlled
trial
we're still waiting for the data from
this drug
do you have any concerns though about
the president promoting this drug
especially since the fda has said
you should not take this drug outside of
a hospital or not
involved in a clinical trial for this
does this concern you
well but remember in general this is a
very very safe drug
people have taken it from malaria
prophylaxis for decades
people have taken it for lupus without
complications
and so i think it is safe but i do not
think the president of the united states
nor any politician
should be promoting individual therapies
without data
this should not be part of politics
health shouldn't be political it is not
a republican or democratic issue
it's all of our personal issues and i
think we have to rise above
the political nature of this drug and
these talking and
talk about other things regarding data
and
not recommending a drug so i don't think
it's right that anybody
recommend a drug until the data have
shown it
so the president doing this does not
define that any patient in the country
should emulate it
because we don't know that conversation
with the physician
all right david higgins thank you very
much